to this day
I still remember
my first visit from the tooth fairy
right I was really little I just lost my
first tooth I did everything I was
supposed to do
put the tooth under my pillow went to
bed and my grandma really wanted to
spoil me because I was the first
grandbaby in like a long time and so
that night
she went to my bed
she took my tooth
and she put a ten dollar bill under my
pillow
foreign
this was ten dollars for my two my mom
was Furious
she was like that's not sustainable all
right
we don't have ten dollar per tooth money
in this household okay his teeth are
gonna start depreciating in value and he
won't know why we're about to lie to him
and tell them that the Tooth Fairy broke
do you see you've made his fastest poor
now
but I didn't care about any of that I
woke up
I was blown away ten dollars it was the
most money I had ever seen at one time
okay I don't even know who this dude is
ten dollars for one tooth next one
already loose
and so I got to thinking like wow if I
save up enough of these
I can buy my own Lego set right
I won't have to ask my parents or
anything because here's the thing when
you're a kid
and you ask your parents for something
that they would love to give you but
they have to say no because they don't
have the money that hurts
and you don't get it you don't fully
understand because you're a kid but you
know something's wrong and I never want
to make my mom and dad feel like that
I even got to thinking if I save up
enough of these I can just give the
money to my mom and help with the rent
because she's always stressed about it
and I was thinking about all this
when across from me I was sitting
outside of my house and across from me
there's no polite way to say so across
me on the sidewalk there was a crackhead
that was dancing right
into any
music right
[Music]
and as I looked up at him dancing I saw
a tooth fall out of his head
and so I being a young entrepreneur
all right
[Applause]
approached him and was like sir I just
noticed
that you lost I mean technically they
landed on my property but I want to be
respectful to you I was wondering if you
wouldn't mind part you already parted
with it but I'm wondering if you would
let me have your tooth
and then he said
[Music]
thank you
my tooth
you want my tooth yes sir if I could
have the tooth
that would help me out a lot
and he was like
[Music]
and I was like oh
um
three
and so then I paid the man who went
about my way because in my head I'm
about to flip this anyway
take money to make money right
and so then that night I put the tooth
under my pillow
I had sweet dreams of Lego sets and paid
rent
and when I woke up
there was a grown man's tooth under my
pillow I was Furious
I was so angry and this is the thing I
know I'm the only one that thinks this
but I actually think that we should
teach kids to curse all right because
one they're gonna learn anyway okay and
two one of the things that can make kids
unbearable sometimes they don't have the
words to express how they're feeling
right
like if I woke up and saw the tooth and
known the word damn I would just say
damn and been done with it right but
because I'm little and I don't know any
curse words I was stomping around the
house just like oh
you know that
[Applause]
you like when you literally you get
stiff leg oh
and my mom saw me and she grabbed me she
was like baby what's wrong and I was
like
because you know you can't talk when
you're little are you that bad
my mom was like calm down
tell me what's wrong use your words
and I was like
I put a tooth under my pill last night
the Tooth Fairy didn't come you're
supposed to give me a promises show me
money this is crazy
and my mom was like you lost another
tooth already
and I was like no
so then she had to go see
oh my God
[Laughter]
so she walked to my bed
she flipped over my pillow
and then she grabbed the tooth and she
was like where did you get this
I'm like from the man she's like what
man
because in my mom's mind there's like a
grown man out there selling teeth
which I mean she wasn't wrong